destrucción mutua asegurada Este es un
concepto usado en las relaciones
internacionales para exponer que en el
caso de un enfrentamiento nuclear entre
superpotencias no habría ganadores con
el anuncio de Vladimir Putin sobre la
suspensión de la participación rusa en
el último tratado sobre el control de
armas nucleares la carrera por la
disuasión nuclear podría reiniciar
no pueden ser gente tonta quieren darnos
una derrota estratégica mientras se
arrastran hacia nuestros objetos
nucleares estratégicos con respecto a
esto tengo que decir que Rusia suspende
su participación en el tratado New Start
Permíteme repetir Rusia no abandona el
tratado sino que suspende su
participación
la declaración del presidente ruso
preocupa al bloque occidental desde la
paz forjada entre mijail gorbachov y
Ronald Reagan que dio fin a la Guerra
Fría el mundo No había experimentado la
atención por una catástrofe nuclear
hasta hoy
más armas nucleares y menor control de
estas hacen el mundo más peligroso
es por ello que la otan ha trabajado
tanto por implicar a Rusia en el control
de armamentos y porque nuestros aliados
han apoyado el New Start hoy pido a
Rusia que reconsidere su decisión de
suspender su participación en el Start
[Música]
Rusia y Estados Unidos abarcan cerca del
90% del Arsenal nuclear conocido a la
fecha Aunque
Moscú tiene más cabezas nucleares
Washington tiene más armas listas para
ser accionadas la Guerra Fría fue el
último período donde la tensión nuclear
fue protagonista hoy la historia podría
repetirse